Spider-Man: Far From Home is an intense game-changing
movie that clocks in at over two hours long,
but there are still some amazing deleted scenes
cut from the final film as well as a completely
different alternate ending.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing 16 deleted scenes,
cancelled characters, and the ending to the
movie you never got to see!
I've got a new Marvel giveaway on this video,
so subscribe, hit the bell and let me know
what you thought of Far From Home for a chance
to win!
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care if
you haven't seen it yet.
The movie's writers Chris McKenna and Erik
Sommers have revealed there are deleted scenes
with Happy Hogan where he's "stumbling through
different descriptions" and trying to come
up with a term of his own for Peter's Spider-Sense.
In the final film, however, it's Aunt May
who gets to name Peter's special power in
the MCU.
"I thought that you could sense that with
your 'Peter Tingle'"
The reason the writers chose Spidey's aunt
to coin that particular phrase was to dial
up the embarrassment factor for Peter.
"Do not start calling it my Peter Tingle."
The worst thing for Pete is that May has also
told Happy and it looks like the term is gonna
stick.
"You get that Peter Tingle back online."
Before Peter left for his school trip to Europe,
originally he had a long to-do list of things
that ended up being cut from the final film/movie.
"Did you get your passport?"
"Peter Parker here to pick up a passport please."
"Yeah."
"Any toothpaste?"
"Uh huh."
"Take down the Manfredi mob?"
"Yeah I did."
And there's an awesome extended action scene
of Peter taking down the Manfredi crime syndicate.
"You gonna be the next Iron Man, now?"
"Well no, I don't have time, I'm too busy
doing your jobs."
"Oooh!
What?!"
"I'm kidding, I'm kidding, look, keep up the
good work!
Because I am going on vacation!"
"I love that guy."
This deleted scene is a nice bit of street-level
action and feels similar to how Spidey took
down the ATM criminals in Spider-Man: Homecoming.
The Manfredi crime family are prominent Spider-Man
villains in the comics and hardcore MCU fans
may also recall that they appeared in the
second season of Agent Carter where Joseph
Manfredi was the leader of a bigger crime
syndicate called the Maggia.
Also on the To-Do list that was cut from the
movie was Peter getting the "dual headphone
adaptor" he wanted for watching movies together
with MJ, as well as a European travel plug,
and toothpaste.
For this he visited Delmar's Store which previously
featured in Homecoming.
"Planning a trip?"
"Uh, going to Europe.
It's a school trip."
Remember in Spidey's first solo film that
Mr Delmar thought Spider-Man was fighting
the Avengers when he saw him taking on some
masked criminals.
In fact, Delmar's bodega was destroyed when
the criminal's tech spun out of control during
that fight.
After the deli caught fire, Spidey jumped
in to rescue Mr Delmar and his cat Murph.
And you can see that moment referenced in
the deleted scene in the newspaper cuttings
that are up on the wall.
Also chopped from the new movie was Peter
going to collect his passport for his trip
abroad.
"Peter Parker here to pick up a passport please."
That dialogue sounds like the writers were
going for something along the lines of the
well-known tongue-twister 'Peter Piper picked
a peck of pickled peppers'.
Now, you might have noticed that this passport
doesn't have any years on it either for Peter's
year of birth or for the issue or expiration
dates.
The years may have simply been removed to
avoid potentially giving away any spoilers
for Endgame.
However, Marvel did mess up the timeline in
Spider-Man: Homecoming with an 8-year time
jump which they had to retcon later when they
released an official timeline for the MCU.
So, perhaps leaving out the dates is a little
nod to that?
By the way, there's a nice easter egg in the
day and month for Peter's birthday on the
passport.
The tenth of August 1962 was the date that
Spider-Man debuted in Marvel Comics.
Another deleted scene from Peter's trip preparations
saw him selling all of his toys to raise enough
money for the Black Dahlia necklace that he
buys for MJ in Venice.
The scene had Peter getting a little emotional
because among the various toys that he was
selling were some vintage Star Wars action
figures that were supposed to have originally
belonged to Uncle Ben.
The action figures appeared on the shelf in
Peter's room in Homecoming, and there's one
character, Lobot, which is a favourite of
Marvel Studios chief Kevin Feige, that Peter
would have ended up keeping.
Lobot is Lando Calrissian's administrator
in Cloud City, and although he doesn't get
any speaking lines in Empire Strikes Back,
he does wear a distinctive-looking cybernetic
headpiece which enables him to communicate
with the city's central computer.
The irony of this deleted scene is that although,
as we've known since Civil War, Peter Parker
is a Star Wars fan;
"Hey guys, you ever see that really old movie?
Empire Strikes Back?"
Actor Tom Holland has admitted that he's not
really into Star Wars himself and hasn't even
seen The Empire Strikes Back, so he doesn't
really know who Lobot is.
By the way, Peter scrabbling to get some money
together to impress MJ with a gift in the
MCU reminds me of how Tobey Maguire's Peter
Parker took part in a wrestling match with
the idea of buying a car to impress Mary Jane
in Sam Raimi's first Spider-Man film.
Far From Home's director Jon Watts and Tom
Holland have both said that all these deleted
scenes in New York were cut because the intention
was to get Peter and the other students to
Europe as quickly as possible.
These discarded scenes will be appearing as
part of a Marvel One-Shot, a bonus short film
which will be on the movie's Blu-ray release.
There's a moment in Far From Home where Nick
Fury tranquilises Ned with a dart in a scene
that calls back to Captain America: The Winter
Soldier.
Peter's been dodging Fury's phone calls so
Fury's/he's arrived in person to ask for Spidey's
help.
And as they leave the hotel room, there's
an amusing clip that ended up getting cut.
"Is he gonna be OK like that?"
"Might wanna turn him over so he doesn't swallow
his tongue."
One location that Peter almost visited with
his classmates on their European tour is New
Asgard, which is where the surviving Asgardians
settled after the events of Ragnarok, and
where Thor and co were hanging out, playing
video games in Avengers: Endgame.
It could have been fun to see Peter Parker
cross paths with Valkyrie, the new Queen of
Asgard, and also check in with Miek and Korg
for an update on Noobmaster69.
The movie's mid-credits scene was pretty amazing
with the surprise return of J.K. Simmons'
J. Jonah Jameson as a conspiracy theorist
commentator for The Daily Bugle website, offering
up one of his typically prejudiced rants where
he twists the truth about Spider-Man, saying
he's the real villain.
Fans have been going crazy for this ending
as it brings back one of the most popular
characters and actors from the Sam Raimi trilogy,
however, originally an alternate ending was
considered that could have brought Anthony
Mackie's new Captain America in for a post-credits
scene or late on in the movie's third act.
In an interview with ComicBook.com, Marvel
Studios' creative executive Eric Carroll said
they discussed bringing in Falcon's Captain
America "at the end, [...] once Peter arced,
and he's sort of [...] leading the team, [...] maybe
he calls in a favour [from Sam Wilson]."
However, this likely didn't happen because,
as Kevin Feige has said, Far From Home is
ultimately about Peter "getting out of the
shadow, not just of Tony but of the Avengers
in general."
"Are you going to step up or not?"
So although Mackie's Captain America missed
out on debuting in Far From Home, he'll be
taking on Cap's mantle for the first time
in his new Disney+ series "Falcon & The Winter
Soldier".
You can learn more about why Steve chose Falcon
to be his successor and discover the future
of Captain America in my other video.
There's a card for that here and in the video
description.
Other characters that could have appeared
in Spider-Man's second solo movie are the
villains Scorpion and the Vulture.
Actor Michael Mando's introduction to the
MCU as Mac Gargan was teased in Homecoming's
mid-credits scene where he tried to find out
Spidey's true identity.
"This?
It's not on you.
It's on our little spider friend.
I've got some boys on the outside who would
love to meet him.
You know, take a picture, slice his throat,
put his head in a dryer.
And I heard a rumor.
You know who he is."
When asked by ComicBookMovie.com why Vulture
and Scorpion weren't included in the sequel,
Jon Watts said "We never really found the
right moment to do something like that.
But […] they're both still out there, and
[…] as we move forward with these films,
we're building out this rich world that we
can continually draw from."
Indeed, with Spider-Man's identity now exposed
by Mysterio's leaked video, Mac Gargan's Scorpion
is bound to take a very keen interest in Peter
Parker and he may try to get his friends on
the outside to target Peter as he already
threatened.
Before the film came out, there was also talk
that Norman Osborn might make an appearance,
with rumours suggesting that he or Oscorp
are the new buyers of the Avengers Tower.
Although we do see Spidey swing by near the
Avengers Tower, any indication of who may
have bought the building has been cleverly
hidden.
However, when Jon Watts was asked about Norman
Osborn, he explained that Osborn wasn't considered
for this film in the end, but that he is still
available for a future story.
Jessica Drew, aka Spider-Woman, is another
character that Marvel was reportedly considering
to make her MCU debut in Far From Home.
Apparently, two actresses in particular were
seriously considered for the role.
First was Shailene Woodley who played Mary
Jane Watson in The Amazing Spider-Man 2 before
her character was cut from that movie.
And there was also Olivia Cooke who you may
know from Ready Player One.
Sources for The Hashtag Show suggested that
Jessica Drew was going to be introduced as
a "Bond-girl type international agent" that
Peter would meet on his trip to Europe.
Given Spidey's incredible popularity, it's
surprising that there still hasn't been a
live-action incarnation of Spider-Woman, but
hopefully that could change soon.
One character that Jon Watts confirmed was
considered for Spidey's sequel is Captain
Britain.
Clearly, Peter Parker's trip to London would
have been a great opportunity for a potential
cameo, especially after Avengers: Endgame
where Peggy Carter's mention of Braddock hints
at the existence of Captain Britain in the
MCU.
However, according to Watts, they just couldn't
come up with a "clever way of incorporating
Captain Britain" into the Far From Home script
and their attempts to do so ended up feeling
like "shoehorned in reference[s]".
A character that Homecoming neatly set up
for future appearances was Miles Morales.
When Donald Glover's The Prowler appeared
in Spidey's first solo MCU movie he mentioned
his nephew, Miles.
However, Miles didn't appear in Far From Home
primarily because the character had just had
a high-profile introduction, albeit in animated
form, in Spider-Man: Into The Spider-Verse.
Despite this, Jon Watts has said that Miles
could still be introduced in live-action in
a movie further down the line.
By the way, Tom Holland himself had a deleted
cameo as another Peter Parker in Into The
Spider-Verse.
A couple more trailer scenes I spotted which
weren't in the movie include this one of MJ
and the newly-in-love couple Betty and Ned
passing through customs.
And there's an extended scene of Peter's encounter
with the Italian customs officer which was
trimmed down in the final movie.
"Questo?"
"They're my pyjamas.
You know .. pyjamas.
They're bigger because..
That's how I like them."
"Pyjamas, OK, that's fine."
And when Hydro-Man emerges from the Venice
canals to wreak destruction [on the city],
it looks like this shot of Peter perched on
the roof of a Venetian bridge was chopped
from the film.
The shot in the actual movie has Peter in
a different position and wearing a [purple]
carnival mask.
So, what do you think about any of these deleted
scenes and do you wish any had been included
in the movie?
Share your thoughts in the comments below
and be sure to subscribe to enter the Spider-Man
giveaway!
Congratulations to the winner of my Toy Story
4 giveaway!
Email me from my About page so I can send
you the prize.
And if you enjoyed this, do hit that thumbs-up
button and tap left to watch another Marvel
video or tap right for some more Spider-Man
or other videos you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!